as an actor i have noticed you have very
expressive eyes you can do a lot with
just your eyes
i know that you like to run around and
wear outlandish costumes and get
attention but when you are still and
you're just using your eyes you really
nail it you know what it's how i got
into business um you know for every
african-american you are probably as an
actor you're on csi one two three cyber
uh new orleans yeah as a villain or a
criminal i mean and when you go in and
murder a number two and this was my
beginning i was murdering number two i
used to go in and i would look at the
cast and then you're like let's get in
tight on these eyes so you'd give those
eyes
right because that's the murderer that's
the murderer
what yeah what'd you say yeah and they
would go oh you got the job
and then you go with up with the
eyebrows and that lets you know you're
shack nice you know what yeah yeah
oh hi
how are you me and andre brower
sometimes we have whole scenes where
we're like hey
[Laughter]
can you do like scared i can do scared
[Laughter]
i can actually wiggle one ear at a time
i am a freak of nature i have the
world's biggest tongue is that even how
do you do shy can you do shy
too shy
there's a shy guy right there
that move was the worst
i got that too this is acting class this
is acting 101 oh look at that see i just
look like i'm constipated whenever i'm a
tough guy
it looks like i haven't gone to the
bathroom in four
and then weeks shy
yeah and i move my hair that's what i do
oh yeah that's the 50 shades of red
right there yeah
end on sexy give us sexy just before we
go to commercial
[Laughter]
[Applause]